yatin HIV is not a death sentence we are
people to more than a million people in
Russia live with HIV and the epidemic
there is growing it's estimated over 250
people become infected every day I don't
like it when they call me HIV written or
spread of AIDS I get the worst abuse and
back alleys Vitaly is one of the few gay
people in Russia living openly with HIV
the only thing that makes me different
are the four pills I take every day
young people taking medication for HIV
can expect a near normal life expectancy
but living with the disease in Russia
brings many challenges the extreme
stigma against HIV positive people in
Russia stems from fear many still think
HIV can be transmitted by breathing the
same air that hiv-positive people should
be rounded up denounced and sent away to
the moon or to marks so we slowly die
off potentionally master-student
oscilloscope with you it's very hurtful
we traveled to several ski a sleepy
mining town with 26,000 residents in the
northern Urals 4% of the population here
lives with HIV the disease has spread
beyond the high-risk group such as gay
men and drug users what do the people
who live here think people are affected
they should really watch their hands
should get vaccinated against HIV
something like that there are lots of
rumors going around here it's one of the
biggest problems do you have
hiv-positive friends yes I do many
they're all sick there's a lot of
unemployment many young people simply
have nothing to do
and many of them are drug addicts half
the people here are junkies city
authorities are trying to prevent new
infections with free blood tests and
public information campaigns making
several scan example for other Russian
cities one of our methods is educating
the population on how to protect
themselves how to live a proper healthy
and active life and we talk a lot about
the importance of restoring family
values not talking about sex but of
marriage and romantic relationships
Family Values against HIV to find out
more on this strategy we head to the
cities Town Hall
these young people are singing
traditional Soviet songs and they say
lessons from the past can help their
future
[Music]
sinless we want to pass on the values of
older generations to our young people
we're helping them to understand what
love is including love for our homeland
that's what these communist songs are
about and that's part of our HIV
prevention plan Russian society has
become more socially conservative in
recent years and that's something that
international AIDS charity Evert says is
a barrier to HIV prevention and
treatment
I only taught my mother eight years
after I was infected the first thing she
said was we had such high hopes for you
so that meant that I was finished in my
mother's world hiv-positive people are
no longer human they're dead
to shatter the stigma against HIV vitaly
started a one-man campaign holding a
sign encouraging strangers to come up
and give him a hug his sign reads I'm
HIV positive
hug me if you're not afraid it's a
protest against isolation in society
you're not to get no I'm a doctor
good job can we hug
only if you not scared why should I be
thank you
it seems like a pediatricians applies
you know it if any more people hug me
then I'm going to cry it really touches
me this makes me stronger and I'm
beginning to realize that I didn't do
this for nothing
maneet also sistema de pasión you read
ecology with switch